your parents listen your podcasts they
do now yes we had to teach them how to
download a podcast because they've never
died before
yeah yeah well I dunno I called home and
my mom I was like mom what are you doing
she said I'm watching your podcast on
YouTube and I said mom we're not on
YouTube well yes you are and I was like
I called my sister Janet I was like
where do you have mom on the Internet
be careful like because you know you do
you find stuff that we're not we're not
going on your lady scent and you never
YouTube so this is your mom Janet yeah
King our family how to download a
podcast you can't watch the podcasts on
YouTube is your sound on your phone is
your sound on there should be a show
about that yeah older people getting
into technology I would watch that well
the first time I mom sent me an email
she called me and she said why haven't
you responded to my email and I said
well what email did you address did you
send it to and she said well it said -
and I wrote Jenna just friend girl jenos
finder not even at anything Jenna she
wrote a long letter and hit Send I was
like mom it doesn't work like that I
never got it oh my god I would do that I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this